I'm standing in a Suburban Street in
Southwest London or at least that side
of the street is in London that side of
the street is in the county of Sur
outside London the outer boundary of
London divides one side of this street
from the
other that has all sorts of consequences
for the residents on both sides
residents on the Su side pay about 10%
more in property taxes than those on the
London side older people living on the
London side get to travel free on
underground trains while those living on
the S side
don't and if you call an ambulance to an
address on one side of the street a
different Ambulance Service responds
than would respond on the other side
apart from all those practical
differences the fact that the London
boundary divides this neighborhood in
half is important when it comes to
showing data about areas on
maps we often show data for areas on a
type of map called a COR pleth map where
each area for which we have data is
represented by a polygon and the color
of the polygon shows a value from the
data so for example on this map darker
Shades represent higher levels of Health
inequality and lighter Shades represent
lower
levels lots of statistical data is
published for Geographic areas rather
than for individual addresses or streets
so if you want to know about poverty in
this area or health or any number of
other things you'll be able to find data
for different areas that contain this
street but you typically won't find data
for the street itself that's because
some streets have only a few houses on
them so publishing data at address or
street level would risk breaching the
privacy of the people who live here
agencies that publish data about places
have to choose which areas they publish
data for for example the government
publishes estimates of poverty in each
local government Ward then also
Aggregates that data into estimates of
poverty at local Authority level and at
Regional level and at National level
publishing data for administrative areas
like Wards buroughs and regions is
useful for lots of reasons for example
it could help a local counselor
understand problems their own Ward might
face but one issue with administrative
areas is that their boundaries tend to
change every few years to reflect
changes in population that makes it
difficult to answer questions about how
things like poverty have changed over
time to get around this problem
governments tend to also publish data
for a set of statistical areas that
change much less often like the
administrative areas there are typically
several nested levels of statistical
area in England for example statistical
data is published for small areas called
output areas which are then grouped into
progressively larger areas with data
sets being published for areas at each
level
statistical data for local areas can
tell us a lot about these places but
there is one problem we need to be aware
of this is called the ecological fallacy
the problem here is that when we look at
maps that show data for different areas
our brains tend to assume that the data
shown for a particular area applies
equally to every street house or person
in that area equally when there's a
difference between two areas on a map we
tend to assume that the difference
happens at the boundary between those
areas this is a problem because in fact
it's quite likely that places just one
side of the boundary or the other tend
to be pretty similar to each other
despite looking quite different on a
corle
map so whenever we look at a map that
shows data for areas we need to remember
that the data only represents a summary
of each area as a whole rather than
telling us something about any
particular Street or place within that
area because of the ecological fallacy
we generally avoid using corle maps to
show data that we could show in a more
detailed way for example it's almost
always better to show hotpots of crime
using a density map rather than a chop
plma but sometimes we have little choice
but to use a corpath map because data is
only available for areas not in
individual
locations so in summary lots of useful
data is published for areas rather than
individual streets or
addresses governments typically publish
data for both administrative and
statistical areas and whenever we use a
corop map we need to consider the
ecological
fallacy